[MUSIC]
We will now talk about how this issue of
zeros in
randomized algorithms can be addressed. And
it's not a minor annoyance,
it's actually a serious issue because
randomized algorithms do
do not like working with
zeroes.
We will now learn how to deal with zeroes
in the profile matrix.
And in the real world, there is always a
possibility
that we do not observe one of the possible
events.
In this case, we assign them the empirical
probability zero.
But in fact, their real probability is not
zero.
It's simply the size of our sample is too
small.
And randomized algorithm hate zeroes
because zeroes
affect their performance in a serious
way.
That's why we need to learn how to get rid
of zeroes.
Fortunately, Laplace helped us to figure out
how to do this.
Laplace calculated the probability that
the sun will not rise tomorrow,
given the fact that it has risen in the
last 5,000 years.
And this probability is roughly
one in two million, according to Laplace.
His estimate was ridiculed because his
opponents
did not realize how important this
calculation was.
If we repeat an experiment that
can result in a
success or a failure n times and get s
successes,
then what is the probability that the next
repetition will be a success?
In other words, if X_1, X_2,
X_ conditionally independent Boolean
random variables (where failure corresponds
to 0 and success corresponds to 1),
then the traditional way to compute
the probability of X_ is simply
to compute the fraction of successes among
among all trials, so it will be s/n.
However, since we have a prior knowledge,
that successes and failures exist, then
they actually have
two more observations implicitly, even
before we started our trials.
So, even before we started our trials we
should acknowledge that success and
failure are possible and
therefore there are two more "invisible"
events.
That was Laplace argument, and therefore
he made a correction
based on the fact that when we see n
events, we actually see n+2 events.
And when we see s successes, we actually
see s+1 successes,
and the formula changes to (s+1)/(n+1).
It may sound counter-intuitive but let's
see how Laplace
would get rid of zeroes in the profile
matrix.
In this case, what we need to do
to update the profile matrix to get rid of
zero?
According to the Laplace's rule of
succession, we
should assume a possibility that every
event represented in the
profile matrix can argue.
And therefore we should add 1s to every
entry of the profile matrix.
And here I show how Laplace would update
the
the count matrix by adding 1s
to all entries.
As a result, the profile matrix also will get
updated, all probabilities
will get updated, and we
will get rid of all zeroes.
Now, instead of a rolling a one-sided die, we
can actually roll a seven-sided die.
And based on the result of rolling a seven-sided
die, we will
choose a new instance of the motif in the
sequence.
Here it is.
Afterwards, we iterate, and let's see how
our motifs are changing.
Starting from this, we once again
continue
with Gibbs sampler,
remove one of the sequences,
form motif matrix, build count matrix,
it
update it with pseudocounts by adding ones to every
entry,
compute profile matrix once again, compute
probability of every k-mer,
and once again roll a seven sided die.
The seven-sided
die leads to changing once again one of
the choices of our motif and we
start a new iteration.
Again, we randomly remove one of the
sequences, construct count matrix,
apply Laplace's rule of succession,
create profile,
calculate probability again,
roll a seven-sided die,
and derive (once again,
starting from completely random motif),
in just three iterations,
we almost captured the correct
implanted motifs.
Which means that the bias that implanted
motif introduced was correctly
captured by Gibbs Sampler, and led us to
the correct motif.
We are not still there, because, in the
second
sequence, we have not found the correct
motif yet.
But surely, at the next iteration, with
high probability, we'll find it.
We're almost
done with covering randomized algorithms,
but the
challenge of predicting the degenerative
signals remains.
Remember how randomized motifs search did
not find
the perfect binding sites for
this motif?
What can we do?
Well, there is one possibility.
Maybe, maybe we can develop even better
algorithm for finding motifs, but if you
think about this, imagine that you implant
not
not a motif motif of length 15 with 4
mutations,
but motif of length 15 with 5
mutations.
Finding this motif is almost
impossible, not because we don't have
efficient algorithms, but because random
motifs
start competing with real motifs. Simply
statistically,
it may not be possible to
find this motif if we
implant them in long DNA strings.
For example into strings of length 1,000.
Well, what can be done?
Should we give up in this case?
Biologist did not give up and the
way to solve this problem today is
to resort to the technique
which is called ChIP-sequencing.
Essentially what the cheap ChiP-sequencing
does, it reduces the length of DNA strings
to look for regulatory motifs.
As I mentioned, when you insert elusive
patterns in the
strings of length 1,000, it may not be possible
even to find it even with the best
available algorithms.
But if biologists reduced the area
where to look for motif, let's say
from 1,000 to 100, then suddenly
statistics works in our favor, and we can
find such motifs.
And this is the end of the story about
randomized algorithms.